Trump's
opponents the really squish Republicans
and the libs have a new line of attack
and that is that Donald Trump is going
to be a dictator uh Robert Kagan who's a
a foreign policy fixture in Washington
uh he said on Friday uh and he this is a
Washington Post editor at large he he
said a trump dictatorship is
increasingly
inevitable we should stop
pretending not increasingly likely
increasingly
inevitable I always liked the kagens
Robert kagan's father was a professor of
mine a an amazing incredible Professor
an incredible historian I expect more of
the Kagan family than this kind of
hysterical nonsense but he's not the
only one this was clearly coordinated
ishan Thor the fear of a looming Trump
dictatorship this was in the post the
Atlantic announced on Monday that it's
going to have a special issue that warns
of the grave and extreme consequences if
Trump were to win in 2024 argues that
Trump and Trump is imposing existential
threat to America and the ideas that
animate
it couple conclusions from this one the
libs believe that Trump is going to be
the nominee they were going after Dan
santis for a little while that's over
they have not really gone after haly yet
they'll see I guess if she can if she
can show movement poll numbers they
haven't gone after Chris Christie they
haven't they're going after Trump they
think that Trump is the nominee Biden is
already treating Trump as the nominee
Trump is already treating Trump as the
nominee now the Washington establishment
is doing that too the other scarier
conclusion I draw from this
is the purpose of this kind of
language is to justify violence against
Trump that's what this is
about there is no evidence that Trump is
going to be a dictator we know that we
know that there's no evidence of this
cuz Trump was already elected one time
he wasn't a dictator I in fact I wish he
had wielded power more effectively he
did he did a good job I'm not really
knocking him too much but I wish he had
done even more we know he's not a
dictator we know that he won't stay in
office forever because he left office
voluntarily even after they rigged the
election on him and there was a lot of
evidence that they rigged the election
we all saw with our eyes he still left
office so there's the only reason to say
this guy he's a dictator he poses an
existential that is to say life or death
threat to our country is to justify
violence against him the Liberals
justify violence against a whole lot of
people they've done it for many many
years they say that our speech is
violence that's why they encourage their
their militant Wing to go attack us on
campuses I got a I got a very nice
welcome here at Clemson last night when
I went to Pittsburgh in the spring
antifa militants tried to blow me
up and why did the antifa militants try
to blow me up because for years we've
had mainstream Democrats say you can't
be civil with Republic Republicans you
got to push back on them in public
spaces you got to go to their homes
where the children sleep and scream and
intimidate them and then what do you get
then you get the attacks that's what
this is about and it's the last thing
they have left to do they robbed Trump
by RI rigging the election they robbed
Trump of his administration in in some
ways by uh constantly trying to undercut
it with all these bogus investigations
that were cooked up based on nothing
where the FBI colluded with the
Democrats and with the Hillary Clinton
campaign to use fake evidence to spy on
Trump's campaign to stop him from
getting elected in the first place he
gets elected to undermine his
administration and the ability to
actually get things done and then they
change all the election laws and rig the
election so they can boot him out then
he's still coming back he's still
popular so they're going to indict him a
bunch of times at the local level at the
federal level they're going to try to to
put him in prison for 700 years and if
that doesn't work there's nothing left
to do what are you going to the only
thing you going to do is say that guy is
going to be a tyrant he's going to seize
power he's going to kill kill the
country existential threat and and so
what does that imply it implies that the
lib should kill him first that's what
they're after right now go to hall.com
the holidays are rapidly approaching but
we can find peace in the craziness of
the season with hallow the number one
Christian Prayer app in the world
immerse yourself in Christmas and Advent
prayers meditations and peaceful
Christmas music hallo also offers an
extensive library of Bible reading plans
accompanied by insightful Reflections
and Audi guided meditations whether you
are a seasoned Bible reader or just
starting your journey hallow provides a
platform for you to engage with
scripture like never before a great
place to start is with father Mike
schmitz's Bible in the year in which he
offers brief daily readings and
Reflections available on the Hallow app
the Hallow app also helps you connect
with a community of like-minded
individuals sharing experiences insights
and encouragement along the path to
spiritual growth this Christmas join
Hallow's Christmas prayer challenge
Advent with CS Lewis for the 25 days
leading up to Christmas you can focus on
the real reason for the season with
prayer meditation and Christmas music on
hallow Advent music as I prefer download
the app for free at hall.com
kwes for three months free that is
hall.com noes so is Trump going to be a
dictator he was asked this question by
Sean Hannity here's the response to be
clear do you in any way have any plans
whatsoever if reelected president to
abuse power to break the law to use the
government to go after people you mean
like they're using right now under no
circumstances you are promising America
tonight you would never abuse power as
retribution against anybody except for
day one except for he's going crazy
except for day one meaning I want to
close the border and I want to
drill drill that's not that's not
retribution I got I'm going to be I'm
going to be you know he keeps we love
this guy he says you're not going to be
a dictator are you I said no no no other
than day one we're closing the border
and we're drilling drilling drilling
after that I'm not a dictator okay I I
love all that stuff and it's a very
funny answer he first he says Oh you
mean like they're doing you mean am I
going to do all the stuff that they're
doing right now but what he comes to the
final point that he comes to is he says
I'm not going to be a dictator other
than on day one day one I'm going to be
a dictator
meaning Sean Hannity is shocked he's
saying no please don't stop saying this
Donald he goes no no no day one I'm
going to be a dictator I'm going to
build the border wall I'm going to fire
a bunch of people I'm going to do this
I'm going to do that and Hannity says oh
okay so you're not going to be a
dictator right yeah no other than on day
one this answer is the 2024 version of
uh I don't want to live in a country
that Donald Trump is president in and he
says yeah cuz you'd be in jail it's that
quick witted response that people aren't
taking totally seriously but they're not
not taking taking
seriously I think this is a perfect
answer here and it gets to something
that's totally missing at the GOP
debates right now where everyone's just
so tense Trump has that ease he goes oh
yeah yeah am I going to am I going to go
after my political enemies by wielding
government you mean like they've been
doing for my entire public life uh nah
no I don't think so although you know
one of my favorite figures is Al Capone
he's just joke he's just toying with
everyone here including with Shan
Hannity and it's it's very effective
It's very
effective you saw this especially after
I think it was the fourth indictment
Trump comes out and he gives a press
conference and he's cool as a cucumber
do not
underestimate the importance of that
quality at a time where everything seems
so uncertain people are so tense
everyone at each other's throats ease is
a very very attractive quality and I'm
not saying that's the reason why he's 50
points up in the GOP race probably that
is just a structural matter of him
running effectively as an incumbent this
time and his reshaping of the Republican
party and the fact that he's been a big
celebrity for 40 years
but that ease that that that puts at
least his supporters at ease that's kind
of funny that's entertaining that's not
so tense that's not the same old script
that we've seen before that that can be
very very attractive boy what a great
clip that was now hey hey hey ring that
Bell subscribe to the Michael nolles
YouTube channel we'll see you next time